ces morceaux de tuyaux sont présents
dans l'a320 le rafale et des
hélicoptères mais on ne les voit pas
assemblés ils composent un système de
raccordement c'est la tuyauterie
aéronautique
ces raccords sont des pièces qui sont
design et est fabriqué ici aux
clayes-sous-bois elles viennent donc
raccorder ensemble des tubes sur les
aéronefs ses tubes permettant de
véhiculer différents fluides
ces tuyaux transportent des fluides
hydrauliques pour les commandes de vol
le carburant ou encore de l'air
permaswage multinationale américaine
possède une filiale en france un site
implanté aux clayes-sous-bois avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 100 millions de
dollars
la croissance est plutôt bonne et
effectivement lié à deux facteurs la
croissance mécanique de l'industrie
aéronautique mais également une
croissance liée à nos développements
propres c'est-à-dire des nouveaux
produits quand que l'on a pu proposer à
nos à nos clients et qui ont été
intégrés sur des nouveaux programmes
comme l'a350 par exemple airbus
l'italien leonardo ou encore le suédois
saab des constructeurs aéronautiques
clients de permaswage aux
clayes-sous-bois 150 personnes sont
employées autour des tours en commande
numérique pour fabriquer les pièces
régler les machines par rapport à un
programme réglé les outils et faire
l'usinage surveiller les côtes et que
toute la série ou que la pièce unitaire
soit bonne à la fois
j'adore ce que je fais depuis 15 ans je
m'épanouis dans ce domaine actuellement
permaswage recherche de nouveaux
collaborateurs avec des formations en
mécanique pour un salaire annuel entre
25 et 35 milles euros par an vous pouvez
postuler à l'adresse mail affiché en bas
de l'écran